welcome to this video part 10 of the
world championship appetizing serious
presenting remarkable memorable games by
the two participants it's time for cars
and game and I've tried to go through
his games and try to find interesting
games that are not so well known in fact
I have covered quite a lot in recent
years on well asada the challenge 2011
and they have done some coverage of
super tournaments we are very often
taught than some games were featured so
I'm going big back down a bit more time
to 2008 here shown again where he had
black against Alexander who's mon um
probably not GM that all of you know but
he's a very very accomplished play some
longtime coach and assistance of Boris
Gelfand is not playing that that much
nowadays is more focused on being
galphin some yeah top second um so leave
always hovers around 2,600 rating so
very good GM he also beat Kasparov in
two thousand one or two years before I
retired around that time so really a
good good player okay let's see what
happens we get a Queen's Indian and well
I should just mention this was played in
the European club cap the top club
competition of Europe where cards num
has played in this year 2008 those kind
of events the European club cap the
European team championship the Chess
Olympiad they are very good on form or
they're very nice from from a game
point of view because we have some you
have been you have some matcha that you
rather see we are really top players are
playing the kind of strong GM's like
here Carl's and with 2800 something
playing a 2600 GM and you know those
guys with 2,600 they they know a bit
about chess and so they very reliably
get get beaten by the better players and
those are often very instructive because
you cannot really say that the 2600 GM
played play badly because there they
know what they're doing but the other
guys are simply stronger alright so the
Queen's Indian and the Guzman is going
for g3 and Bishop a 6 this is nowadays
the main line getting play against the
spawn and white um for years almost
exclusively has played b 3 however in
recent years a move gained popularity
that was basically considered harmless
for for ages Quincy to just protecting
the pawn who with the Queen and it was
considered harmless because so after
Magnus place this one it was considered
homeless because it was always believed
that the move c5 would give black good
play because the queen is on the C file
and you always thought that okay after
the capture here on after white
capturing the screen is not particularly
well placed but it was was discovered
that white can sacrifice upon you with
d5 take stakes and tip it should be
seven now it's I it's impossible to
protect the pawn this one check is not
not advisable winning a piece but after
Bishop e7 white just gives away the porn
for compensation and it's a very
complicated position
that rises also position which has been
discussed in detail at top level so what
what Carlton is doing is pretty typical
of his starship he plays a secondary
line that is still playable but far less
committal just gives the check and
retreats this is of course a common
theme in the Queen's Indian wear black
argues that this Bishop is not
particularly well placed yeah that is
true but in this concrete position white
has the opportunity to play eform and he
takes it occupy the center blacks idea
as this counter strike two immediately
attacks the center and why it's best
line is what Guzman plate he took on d5
black takes him King takes ed5 and now
e5 this makes lots of sense white can
use g3 as a as preparations now for the
king so this lost castling rights isn't
a bigger problem is the problem and
there your white gain space in the
center black cam occupies the central
post and white is busy to exchange this
active piece and look like it doesn't
have a many much choice takes it
politics and queen to d7 so what is Plex
idea we see in the game Plex ideas
actually to use this night on e six as a
blockading piece I mean this isn't a
pure blockade because the F pawns fy5 is
a possibility but the night only six is
nicely placed behind this pawn on e5
ended support c5 this is blacks general
idea and what white tries to do is to to
break in the center or in the long run
player 45 but we see that why does quick
here we'll see for a good plan and we
can for our only state that white has
a nice position here he doesn't have any
any problems at all and he has some
pressure on the queenside so it's
nothing to worry about at the moment for
white your hair curls up late night to
d8 just going for this maneuver
improving the night using it only six
but of course it's a very concrete
position already the first thing to
check here for white is the capture and
this is in fact what was played in the
game cars and recaptured adhere the
first concrete line needs to be
calculated what about this pawn yeah
white could take the pole and something
to consider 96 is the idea between
retreats probably to c3 and then
something like booty-eight you should be
three and ng5 needs to an interesting
position where black enjoy some
compensation for the pawn it's a it's
really unclear cannot really say that
blackest is having more than
compensation but it's it's an
interesting way to play this pin is of
course the essential idea probably age
three and an even f5 can be considered
still intending g4 and this is just a
complicated position that black and try
to UM yeah play for wind with some risk
of course but it's interesting when
who's my didn't take he played another
move and not a bad one I've not at all
she played Queen a4 check which is
perfectly all right calzon played c 6 cm
for one problem is if you go Queen b7
hear that check that this is very
debatable it's pawn here
severely restrict the night and it's not
so clear black sugar untangle he can
play something like that but it looks it
looks tricky cousin played c6 he didn't
want to exchange Queens also i guess and
try to keep the game going of course he
wants to win this black or at least them
try for winning chances b5 wasn't a good
idea it just weakens the queenside too
much especially up here so c6 and Roxy
wrong yeah and now we get to the first
very critical position of this game yeah
what should like do White has got lots
of pressure here on the on the C file
and yeah normal would be a move like
castles and no it's not not really a bad
move but this is the kind of normal move
you would play then white can try to
build up on the c4 one first idea could
be quincy form where it's a bit of a
problem that black faces you don't
really want him to take and get to the
seventh rank and if you take here white
is very quick with increasing pressure
or would be one a form it's always the
spawn that needs protection if you move
the night on the 8th it is lost i mean
it's it's simply a bit of an it's it's
an advantage for white so on what did
cosplay you played a very very bold move
king d 7
now this is a creative solution the king
is used to do cover blue week porn and
this immediately complicates matters and
sort of provokes white to to try for
something this is just this is a tool to
play for win play a continuation that
puts you on a bit of risk I mean not a
lot a bad move I mean not playing bad
moves but but a bit of provocation can
help um let's see what happens this is
what who's mom played not not bad at all
this bishop on the two wasn't doing much
and it's exchanged against this bishop
that only that also helps in defending
the dark squares and there were many
alternatives of course white also could
have tried to improve or increase here
on the C file which probably after 96
Luke c1 rook c8 maybe this one yeah this
kind of this kind of line could have
been tried a highly idea in this
position as that after g5 threatening
this move white can actually play this
as Queen takes d5 s ruining for white
wins the Queen and it's just the
decisive attack black there's no way to
defend this just an idea like doesn't
need to take you can play a player some
improving moves from instead this one
may be so it's a very complicated
fighting position so many possibilities
white went for this move which as much
it isn't as bad now be five
and a five gaining space and allowing
some additional on giving some
additional options like rook a6 to
defend Luke a 77 this expansion is
helpful queen bee three and 96 and we
can can conclude that black managed by
using this interesting King b7 setup has
managed to to get the night 36 and he's
probably okay here maybe a one of those
more complicated on options like this
rook c3 and said of Bishop before was a
bit stronger white isn't in any trouble
but it doesn't look like he still plays
for from some some edge but okay what
move should why to play here there are
many possible ways to to just keep the
position as it is let's say rook be one
or something just doing not doing much
however there isn't another option which
is also get it most interesting within
the position Guzman now played the
fascinating sacrifice rook takes c6 move
you can you can easily overlook really
with both sides that this should be
possible but in fact it is possible the
first simple point is if you you take
with the king look Susan just wind
service you can you can see quickly King
doesn't have a square where it's not
losing the Queen so this is what like a
black plate and now d 5 so whose mother
sacrificed this this rook to bust open
the center and get the King out in the
open now this position of course
requires good calculations and and great
nurse and bow
the definite strength of Magnus Carlsen
check takes only six certainly the only
move you need to regain some of the
material and King takes the King
advances if you look at the alternative
f takes look do you want check check
King is seven probably necessary going
to the e-file the sir this isn't this
isn't so great attending whoopsie one it
probably needs to go somewhere on the
farm let's say here are two e7 probably
seven and then Queen III and this sir
looks tricky at a screen g5 and attract
the computer gives us as equal probably
leading to some kind of petrol the what
Carl played however King takes c6 it's
simply that he is a very very good term
calculator of variations and he always
tries to play the most challenging way I
mean you could you could first think
okay this is a risky move because the
king is really right out in the open
especially if you consider that white no
plate 94 check and after this blacks a
plan is yeah it's clear what he's doing
is playing teeny five this was the idea
of of the King working text e6 but you
see this is a provocation of white
really 94 as a tempting move and in fact
94s move that really makes it difficult
for why to actually achieve a draw he
can and she would wrong with the precise
play 2 to get a perpetual check but this
is difficult to do and he's always
trying to set
the utmost problems possible check I a
king me five so what what should do I do
now instead of 94 and I should mention
that of course what also could have
played Queen III this is an interesting
way to to keep the game going with this
idea however it's probably not
objectively better 94 is that ok but
it's it's really white needs to be
really precise after that King be five
and here here it gets it gets critical
white now play some very natural-looking
move and it is an ok move but the
problem is after that you're in a
position where you really need to play
the only playable move all the time and
here White had a good alternative let
Queen a three-year sure to check put
that on the board giving away this night
even and I think this is just the most
most obvious booth because of cake do to
you calculate the capture and the king
is even advancing further so this is
also the first move I would calculate it
seems however that and Queen a3 also
what's good move and maybe a somewhat
easier you can this is always debatable
what what move is easier to find this is
of course the idea but what happens if
black can captures Queen takes its even
losing hack due to this this check check
yeah this check until you lose the Queen
at least probably more in fact King
takes is the news that black must play
and yeah what's now now there's more
than one way to get to the draw the
probably easiest or cleanest way is rook
see one the queen is just just detect
and what should like do after
this check check blackest even in some
trouble the squier 3 mate threatened and
after King takes this Queenie 7 check
and black ass I in trouble note that
this is an additional idea here Queen d5
has in fact a mistake what blacker
should do is play rook c8 or queen
before we can look at Queen before
others Queen III she didn't see that
sorry but Roxy 8 is a possibility
intending to recapture let's say check
check and then there's receive the see
Paul giving some color to play probably
this will end in the draw because the
sea part is just very strong and thus
King is so wide open that they were
probably a perpetual that writer needs
to need to take Queen a3 was a possible
alternative you played climate f3 which
is still okay rook takes and now now
exactly now is the critical position
that decides the game Black has done
everything to get to this point where
there needs to be one precise move plate
and who's more flavor fails to do so it
is possible that it was already a bit of
a time issue since I don't have any time
recorded for this game it's possible
that this was some 11 important issue
here he played Queen III check check and
in fact the smooth losses the only way
absolutely only way to draw here was
rookie one with this idea and it seems
that this should should hold the draw
one possible line is so King back check
check right here will you clap we are
already another knocking a sec sorry
Kingda five and now white can play music
this is the point sorry and introducing
introducing this idea yeah what will get
a perpetual here after queen is recheck
um there are some also Queen defly check
can you fire check yet another check can
see that black king is on the run check
now and here we are nearing the check
the perpetual check and that's it
perpetual or let's say black and black
needs to take now if you go see this
checkmate bit of a embarrassing make
black and take and needs to take and now
have six this is the whoops the way to
to go back for the king and these pawns
are a strong white wolf check finish the
game shank with checks so it's all about
precise calculation here and let's
return to the game can be played Queen
III King the five animals and this of
course check fails easily so it's looked
young king e6 yeah and now we see that
chatter Luke d6 was played King 7kg five
King it the King returns from D for all
the way back to e8 and it looks like
dodging bullets but it seems to work
blacks king is is invincible however it
still requires precise plain white not
played e6 and here try to find the best
move this is not easy really the king is
still wide open and of course it has
moved new
those times you cannot castle would be
nice to do but you cannot do that so one
what is the most precise way to play
here note that why does threatening to
to open up the position further or
sometimes play prey up to 7 Martinez
played the the best move here Roxy aid
this is the best move getting the look
into play and it just gets to position
where white has no one yeah no attack
anymore but one amazing point is that in
this position white had one move
available that he didn't play he took
one m7 check after that it's relatively
easy for black an amazing thing about
this position is that after the month H
form that white could have played giving
the King some some room on h2 after age
for that black only has exactly one way
to win and this is quite amazing and
it's a bit of a shame that who's my
didn't play that because it would have
been great to see if Carson would have
found the winning line here it's it's
possible that he would have done so but
it's just a great line let's have a look
black takes the only move that save the
draw amazingly that when sorry I'm sorry
like once win of course and the big
thing is the the the coming move Queen
here and it first looks like a disaster
this is threatened and there are all
kinds of threats here but black has
exactly one moved to to win and this is
the fantastic move rook g8 yeah this is
just amazing quinte jack king is heaven
and we have a double attack with the
king it exposes the Queen to their tech
and threatens look and why it simply has
no no square for the Queen way it
protects the rook on d6 and this shall
also perfectly coordinated so an amazing
resource rookie
it and it's a shame that this wasn't
wasn't played with h4 move because it
would have been great to see if it would
have been found but ok it's not even
over it's a it continues let's let's
check first white can also take here and
what should like do now there's some
still only one move to win look G form
and I mean the point is the point is
completely insane if white now takes the
rook black has this movie it's I know
it's it's very very computer ish but
it's just a fascinating line it
introduces this defense of possibility
and if white takes there's quit f1 Jack
and black gets a vicious counter-attack
check check like that check ya got to
check get the look at the end alright
this is completely insane but it's a
line that needs to be shown because it
shows that sometimes the chest things
are possible that you you simply don't
imagine possible but he didn't play age
for and would have been very interesting
to see what what happened after that she
played the capture and after Queen takes
it was a much easier on defensive task
check Queen B seven check king at shree
look f8 check in turn black black really
keeps everything check under control
check lots of checks but the King runs
away after couple of more moves check
check yeah like a counter text now I
don't really need to show I'll give any
more lines black is completely winning
here why doesn't even have a meaningful
check here and yeah an interesting game
also because of the lines especially h4
would have been an amazing resource that
would have put black under under some
pressure to find the winning
continuation this age for idea with this
fantastic point yeah but what is what is
remarkable about the skin is that in all
his complications black played
absolutely perfect chest I mean there
were many ways to go wrong go go to some
wrong square with the king or blunder or
whatever but he simply didn't he always
played the most challenging move setting
problem after problem after problem and
yeah the people crumble under under in
this situations where the pony is
constantly playing playing good moves
and playing the most demanding moves
that you really don't have any anyway
after you may only have one or two
possible replies and need to find them
and yeah players very strong players
crumble under the pressure yeah I hope
you enjoyed this game bit of an
interesting pls technical game for
change yeah thanks for watching I'll be
back with a new video ya tomorrow thanks
for watching